Harvard has reportedly lost over $1
billion due to the statement made by
their president Dr Gay that's actually
her name I know a lot of people are
making fun of over but that's her name
and uh Harvard is now refusing to remove
her despite the fact that she has made
these as many would say shockingly
offensive statements but that's not the
real Scandal the real scandals that
Harvard covered up a massive plagiarism
Scandal where this individual Dr Gay
actually plagiarized numerous times and
we have this here they are willing to
lose over a billion dollars to defend
this now many people are saying this
this Harvard president is clearly A
diversity hire and I think we are
getting an excellent window into
wokeness right here and that's why this
story is so important an individual who
does not have the merits who lied
cheated and steal and stole reportedly
in order to get into positions of power
and is being actively defended by the
the institution despite the fact they
are clearly not fit to serve in this
role considering all the news that's
come out the loss of money and the clear
lack of capabilities but this is the
point the capture of Institutions is not
about whether someone can actually do
the job it's about whether their
politics align with their new cult-like
religion so we'll talk about that plus
we'll talk about that new Obama movie
where uh they have this line they say
don't trust white people and everyone's
up in arms about it and uh apparently
it's it's a fairly woke film and the
main character is like some racist white
lady so we we'll definitely get into
that and then there's a big debate
happening online after a comic was
produced by one of our favorite artists
G Prime 885 crit uh critical of gay men
having children through surrogacy this
is result resulting in in in in a lot of
drama among a lot of individuals and and
a big debate which I think we'll
definitely get into and then of course
we have a very interesting story about
Millennial women being uh the worst off
since World War II compared to any other
generation so we'll get into that before
we get started my friends head over to
the best song ever.com
click pre-order on Amazon and buy the
song now it's coming out on Friday this
is our collaboration with Michael nolles
and Jeremy boring they wrote a song
called together again mocking the music
industry we made a cover in a modern
style mocking the music industry and
with this we hope to give a big fat
middle finger to the music industry
which has effectively told both the
daily wire and timcast to screw
ourselves even though we've done all we
did was make music now the daily wire of
course is making more movies they did
song we've made music and we've had
various Outlets tell us to go f
ourselves I'm not kidding verbatim go f
yourself an email that was sent to us so
we decided we're just going to mock them
and be more successful if you want to
support us you can pre-order the song
right now it'll be out on Friday and if
we sell enough of them we'll chart on
Billboard and then we get to wag that uh
billboard charting song in front of all
the faces of all the woke institutions
that want to tell us to screw ourselves
but also don't forget to go over to
timcast.net our uncensored membersonly
shows we're going to have one of you one
of those coming up for you tonight at 10
p.m. and you get access to our members
only Discord server where you can hike
where you can hang out with like-minded
individuals and there's pre-shows
there's after shows a ton of really
great content occurring on that Discord
server and also smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
if you really like it sharing the show
is what helps the most joining us
tonight to talk about this and
everything else is Daniel Turner awesome
to be here yes great to be here Daniel
Turner power the future your favorite
fossil fuel advocate in the world and uh
happy to be with you fine folks yeah so
uh Power of the future you're you're
you're basically calling out the uh the
lies from the yes in the green agenda
and we're the only ones not at cop 28
right now it seems like all the cool
people they're in week three of of the
big climate Fest in Dubai um you know
you is that where they all fly on the
private jets exactly you know those of
you who are listening who are like we
had a two-day retreat in Tampa for for
my company it's like yeah try three
weeks in Dubai you got to join the
climate cult and you get to party like a
rock
you imagine how many hookers and cocaine
is in Dubai fun it's all illegal too but
you know if you're in the club yeah of
course it is right on well thanks for
hanging out we got uh lowski Hey guys my
name is lowski here of we are change.org
all the institutions are collapsing and
it's absolutely beautiful to see today I
am wearing my Irish lives matter t-shirt
uh a somewhat controversial statement
that might get you investigated if you
actually wear this in Ireland that's why
I made it a t-shirt that you could get
on thepolitical shirts.com there's
actually two versions of this shirt I'm
wearing the members only shirt that I
had to put tape over uh it has another
special message there that you could
find out if you are a member of Luke
unfiltered.com and I'm going to reveal
the message later but that's one of the
perks of many perks of directly
supporting me on Luke un filter.com Phil
hi good to see you haven't see while how
are you man I'm doing well my name is
Phil abanti I'm the lead singer of uh
the heavy metal band All That Remains
very failed musician uh anti-communist
and counter
revolutionary uh Serge how you doing
homie doing well yourself doing well I
just found out that uh we have seven
Gold Records now oh seven you got
another one another one just went uh
failur keep stacking up yeah just
officially went over today so the uh the
full length the overcome record Went to
went gold so that's wow congratulations
seven Gold Records that's pretty awesome
for a dude that yells at a stick for a
living that's right you know and and and
and and who is a failure yeah failure
that's amazing if you're a failure I
don't know what the rest of us are I
listen I fail I fail
I feel big that's how I do it
so s just here yeah oh all right well
let's jump into the first story we have
this from Fox Business the context is
important Harvard president's handling
of anti-Semitism has cost a school more
than 1 billion according to Bill Amman
billionaire investor and influential
Harvard Alum Bill Amman continued his
push for his Alma moer to terminate
president Claude Dean gay over the
weekend claiming her handling of
anti-Semitism on campus since the
October 7th terror attack by Hamas on
Israel has cost the university more than
a billion dollars in donations in a
letter to Harvard's governing board of
directors posted on the social media
platform X on Sunday acman argued gay
quote has done more damage to the
reputation of the institution than any
other individual in its nearly 500e
history going through a Litany of
criticisms over her leadership which he
says has contributed to Major donor
withdrawals significant gifts that uh
with withdrawing significant GI gifts
that are adding up here's what's
important let's break all this down
because the the articles elves don't
give you this context us today says
Harvard president Claude Dean gay to
remain University leaders affirm support
this is somebody who right now and we'll
get into all the details has been
exposed as a plagiarist who should not
be in this position who does not have
the Merit the skill the capabilities
many people are saying she's clearly A
diversity hire this is an individual
that has failed in regards to the
hearing before Congress has resulted in
a loss of over a billion dollars by any
metric this person should be fired yeah
they will not fire her and why because
the only actual metric Harvard cares
about are you woke are you a member of
our religion and if you are nothing else
matters while the rest of us look to
Harvard and think it's some higher
education institution one of the best
it's not it's a church a church of the
woke and so the actual job description
for this woman is to be a woke Prost
proser
so when she's faced with mounting
criticism the board of directors and all
these other people say okay what are
they criticizing her about oh she's
costing us money she's engaged in a
plagiarism Scandal they actually covered
up a major Scandal we'll get into that
in a bit and then they go okay but
that's not a job description is she
advancing diversity equity and inclusion
yes no she's fine yeah um it and it's
remarkable to see this happening harvy
still has $50 billion in their endowment
so I don't think they're hurting any
anyway at all um but it's it's
absolutely incredible to watch this play
out in real time and wonder what is the
purpose of this University right um
there was another study that came out
today that Yale the majority of the
students at Yale all got A's last
semester you say well if everyone gets
A's I mean these these universities
don't really seem to have any sort of
academic purpose I like that you're
liking them to a church that's the best
way to put them and like a church like
if your parents are members you become a
member I would say they're more like a
hedge fund with a indoctrination Center
or even just a just a factory that
produces the woke mind virus but it's
interesting to see them kind of eat
their own eat themselves and attack
themselves on this very divisive issue
that is Israel when for many years now
they were being very discriminatory they
were being very racist they were
violating the civil rights of
individuals because of the way that they
were born and everyone was okay with
that now that we have the conflict in
Israel people are like okay now we got
to really have to deal with this issue
which uh which I find very peculiar at
this specific time I find it peculiar
that I'll take it no goad no if if you
replaced Israel or anti-semite with any
other minority group and this was the
question facing the University president
would be a different story can you have
call for genocide against trans members
on Harvard campus no if if she did not
stand up if she didn't lie down in in in
in solidarity with a D in on the quad if
she didn't forcefully condemn this
before cut she would have been fired
within seconds but you can for white
people that are technically a minority
on on the world's population and then
that's that's totally toally fine but
but then Bill Amman actually calls them
out for this too there are a lot of
people that are like oh these these
wealthy billionaires didn't say anything
when these universities were
discriminating against white people and
conservatives but now that it's the Jews
they're coming out and no these
billionaires actually are coming on
saying like we didn't realize and you
know what I'll take it I'll take it look
not everybody cares about what you care
about and there's a guy who's dumping
tons of money to University not paying
attention then it affects something he
cares about Israel I'm not going to get
mad that I'm going to say welcome to the
fight thank you for finally paying
attention and calling this out this is
what made you this is what impacted you
impacted you okay well take a look at
what everyone else is complaining about
oh we agree awesome let's win yeah yeah
the that was uh to your point Tim I was
listening last night you guys talk about
uh about Bud Light and that's another
example when you have people that are
looking that are that have have noticed
that there is a problem that you have
been making noise about right you don't
you don't attack them and say oh you
know now you know and push them away you
welcome them into the fold so that way
you have more people on your side
because the whole point of the culture
war is not to get rid of the people that
disagree and this was something that
Jordan Peterson made this point about uh
conservatives the way that the the left
had been treating conservatives what are
you going to do with all the with all
the Donald Trump voters if you if you if
you be you know Donald Trump they're
still Americans and that's a that's
something that we have here in the US
most of the division in my opinion has
been driven by the ideological left
pumping out ideologically motivated
people and they have lied to your
average Democrat your average left
left-leaning liberal person so they're
still right leaning because Liberals are
kind of right leaning the left is
actually a totally different philosophy
so your average left-leaning liberal has
been lied to and and has been tricked
into believing that woke is the
continuation of the Civil Rights
Movement which it is not is a totally
different tradition it's the exact
opposite of that transition as it
promotes discrimination against
individuals for the way that they were
born sorry 100% absolutely yes and and
they're they're waking up to that and we
need to welcome that welcome them back
into the America loving liberal society
that we all are looking to get back to
we talk about all the time we talk about
we want to get rid of the woke we want
to get rid of all this bad ideology and
now is a great opportunity to bring
people back into the American mindset
where America is not always bad and that
it's not always just dump on the liberal
mindset Dave poroy announced he will not
hire anybody from Harvard MIT or upen
until these people are fired he then
said good I think he's he's pulled back
on upen because they did have the member
and the president resign but he
specifically called her out and was like
I'm not going to hire anybody your
degree is worthless anybody who
currently works for me he was asked did
you have people applying he's like well
I have people who work here now but
they're grandfathered in anybody else
you I will not hire you because that
degree James Lindsay was making a very
similar argument saying only then when
people stop hiring these people is when
we could have a big cultural difference
here because that degree won't matter
anymore that Prestige won't mean
anything anymore because they actually
just shot themselves in the foot now
there is a lot of degrees of hypocrisy
especially when it comes to saying yeah
you can hate on this group you can't ha
on this group oh now we're in trouble
for hating on this group but but still I
want to go back a little bit here
there's there's a lot of other
individuals like Cassandra McDonald
making the argument here hey we should
also be careful because we still want to
protect freedom of speech what do you
guys make of the argument here saying
hey uh whatever these policies are I
don't care freedom of speech still
should be protected here is this freedom
of speech and should it be it it be
protected da ptoy was asked about their
stance and he said no you should not be
allowed to call for the genocide of
group of people that's where you're
getting into harm and violence etc etc I
disagree with him I agree with his
position that these people are
hypocrites they're Liars they're
cheaters they're thieves and you should
not hire people who are coming from
these I'm I'm avoiding all that these
are these are corrupt institutions I
suppose it depends on how long ago you
were there or whatever but uh no I
actually I agree with what each and
every one of these individuals said to a
certain degree they said the
Constitution the right of the
individuals to have their opinion if
it's getting to the point where you're
harassing an individual that breaks the
rules I completely agree with that what
I don't agree with is that these people
are lying and spitting in our faces they
scream no pronouns you have to use you
have to use our pronouns they scream no
fat phobia they will ban you from campus
they will shut your speech down and then
the moment it comes to a call for
genocide of the Jews they all of a
sudden say well the Constitution I'm
like you are right the Constitution now
screw yourself I'm not defending you
when are you going to make a fat phobia
shirt because fat phobic lives matter
too fat fat lives matter too I don't
know what the was but we I have a
different point of view I have I have
the exact opposite perspective uh I'm
joking we might get in trouble here on
YouTube if I express it it gets it gets
complicated it gets complicated because
the first amendment clearly says
Congress shall make no law right Harvard
is a private institution it has its own
laws and that's why the congresswoman
Elise stonic asked a very good question
she didn't say it is a violation of free
speech she said is it a violation of
your code of of ethics and as a private
institution it can make its own laws and
Harvard is a private institution saying
calling for violence violates our code
of e ethics well when you say antifa
from The River To The Sea you're calling
for violence so that's why it was really
like connect the dots congresswoman
stepanic set her up perfectly to give a
very good answer that was clear all she
did was unravel this cluster disaster of
of wokeness this is all awesome it was
brilliant all of this the story
everything this is this is why it's the
lead ladies and gentlemen yeah when
Harvard this morning when when the news
broke that they said unequivocally we
will not fire this woman I was like
thank you yeah that's the message we
want to share with everybody they are
they they lie they are hateful they are
racist they are plagiarists your kids
going to these schools will not be
better off
they will be manipulated indoctrinated
and when when when proof was there that
this person should not have this job
they said screw off yeah remember when
the NAACP sent out an announcement
saying that no African-Americans should
go to Florida right they should just
boycot the whole state of Florida
someone else just an LGBT group just did
that the other day I saw it on Twitter
same exact thing raising money to get
people out who are are gay or trans out
of
Florida
will will the anti-de league will will
Abe foxman will one of these Jewish
groups start an an actual boycott of
Harvard to say we call on all Jews to
boycott Harvard because clearly it is a
danger I mean that was the naacp's
argument for Florida you are endangering
yourself if you go to this state well
clearly if you're Jewish you're
endangering yourself if you go to
Harvard I got to be honest I'm not big
on wanting to hire college graduates as
it is so I don't care if it's Harvard I
go to college yeah I don't care if it's
Harvard or go to the Sciences you know
if if you're hire a college graduate
that went to one of the hard Sciences or
that studied something real but if
you're just Hing someone they still
teach them woke trash even in those yeah
they have to I understand that but that
you know that's something that we're
going to have that's something that
actually has to be addressed by culture
though because because you get people
that go and they study them they'll
major in something and they'll minor in
some kind of woke thing and so that
they're laying like a groundwork or or
at least a tertiary knowledge of the of
the the ins and outs of the woke
ideology and that's something that has
to be changed by you know by by the
nightly uh comedy shows the you know
late night shows not reinforcing that
stuff will do a lot well a lot of the
wok up has a lot to do with the
revisioning of capitalism it also goes
all the way back to David Rockefeller
pushing a whole bunch of huge money into
higher institutions of learning that he
was able to influence that of course
undermines the very kind of capitalism
that put him in the position of power
that he was in that of course he was
manipulating and abusing for his own
personal benefit so this has roots going
back many many years ago and now we're
seeing the kind of formation of it and
it kind of just falling on its face
right now with this Harvard kind of
controversy as now we are finally being
exposed to the true kind of hatred and
nature of this socialistic leftist
brainwashing campaign that now finally
is being called out there's one thing I
want you mentioned James James Lindsay a
little while ago and we just had him on
the show that's why I we just had a
conversation I'm a huge fan and I've
mentioned him a lot and I I'm going to
mention him again because right now
the best thing about them allowing the
president to stay uh stay at Harvard is
it it really shines a light on the fact
that that we are living in the logic of
Herbert Mar Hugh's repressive tolerance
the the argument made in that in that
piece is that it's okay to do whatever
you want if you're on the left and the
right must be suppressed at even the
level of thinking right-wing thoughts
and to the left at least in college on
college campuses now every everyone
that's not left of them is the right and
must be censored and has to be shut down
so it's it's good to like I'm with Tim I
think this is good that that that
they're standing behind her it's good
that she's not stepping down it's good
that Harvard is doing this so that way
it shines a light on it so that way the
American people can see all right we do
have a real problem in the United States
now let's focus on MIT that also has
Intelligence Agency connections and
let's expose that whole larger problem
let me pull up the story from the New
York Post this is big news it's
uh just a few couple hours ago Harvard
covered up a secret plagiarism probe
into president Claudine gay during
anti-Semitism storm threatened the post
so this is uh uh ongoing yeah while this
whole Scandal like before this uh this
stuff's going on before at least toic
questions sir apparently she was being
investigated for plagiarism we have this
huge thread from Aaron sarum who says
Chris rufo's examples are just the tip
of the iceberg in four articles
published between 93 and 2017 including
her
dissertation gay paraphrased or quoted
almost 20 authors without proper
attribution in some cases lifting entire
paragraph's verbatim he's got the
evidence right here her dissertation
began it was the best of times it was
the worst of times I mean look look look
this is a massive Scandal where we are
learning that the president of Harvard
plagarized her way into through her
dissertation for for for over 20 years
they know this knew this they covered it
up she then makes shockingly offensive
statements and they refuse to fire her
New York Post reports it's great to be a
leftist yeah that's right you can do
nothing you can do no wrong Hunter Biden
look at that Harvard University covered
up a highlevel investigation into
whether its controversial president was
a plagiarist and used an expensive Law
Firm to threaten the post over our own
probe the college announced Tuesday
morning that had investigated Claud Dean
gay over whether some of her academic
work was plagiarized and had cleared her
of breaching the colleges standards for
research misconduct I will say it again
the only qualification for the job is
that you are a member of the cult and
then everything else is irrelevant she's
a good cult member she serves the cult
should we fire of course not she's doing
her job yeah all that matters is pushing
is pushing the ideology all that matters
is pushing leftist and that's when
that's what I was trying to talk about
with like the NAACP calling for the
boycott of of of of Flor best state in
America these institutions all they do
is push leftist ideas and when they come
into clash with reality if reality is is
not the leftist agenda then reality gets
pushed aside but even if they fire her
even if they fire her they're just going
to replace her with someone just as bad
the same kind of cult member that's
going to be giving out that woke
Kool-Aid the same kind of individual
that's going to be along the same lines
so I don't I don't understand why they
won't fire her and just replace her with
a worse person and then kind of appease
the mob that's trying to what she does
as a as a priest of wokeness the sad
thing is is that as we're having this
conversation there is still a lovely
patriotic quote unquote patriotic no I
won't even quote unquote patriotic
American family that is sitting there
with their 17-year-old daughter and they
are plotting to get her into Harvard
they're waiting for that letter being
like fingers crossed and they're doing
all the essays and they they hear about
this but they're like but we have to get
our daughter Preston Prescott bookcase
whatever her name is we have to get her
into Harvard or Yale or Prince or whever
so this is it right now that has to stop
everyone needs to refuse to work with
people who have degrees from Harvard Mi
and upen uh until they they they back
down and the institutions are are are
recaptured and deified I don't even
think you know Porto was like until they
fired these individuals I'm like you got
to root out the corruption you've got to
you got to grab the the weed and pull it
out by the roots and so my my attitude
is you you you you want to apply to job
here just don't put it on your resume
yeah and and it has to get to the point
that anyone over a certain age Maybe
Harvard 20 years ago was different who
knows maybe it was exactly the same but
at a certain age now if you meet someone
under 30 who is very proud and they brag
that they went to Harvard their response
has to be just pure laughter it's like
when your friends like I'm I'm a huge
Browns fan and you're like you're a
Browns fan like no offense to Browns
fans of course as a Giants fan um right
but it has to get it has to you know get
that gut reaction of just laughter like
oh you went to Harvard oh my God please
what you learn how how to point out the
different races in the room exctly I'm
looking for a guy who knows how to like
I don't know design a building not how
to criticize People based on their race
next next next candidate get out of my
face yeah that and I love the way that
you that Dave port is doing that and
others is saying that that's the best
way to solve these problems is when the
schools become unmarketable because of
the product they create and and that's
that is our own fault culturally as an
as a nation we have elevated these
schools too well I mean he did go to
started you had these Wall Street
investors vowing to not hire any of
these people instantly the students who
fil who signed this document praising
Hamas backtracked and apologized and
they're like oh gez oh no and it's like
no I'll take their apology they now now
the the institu like don't stand behind
this stuff yeah except that if you go
down this path you lose but you know the
issue was there was who was it some guy
said don't hold it against these
students they didn't even know what they
signed I'm like oh now I'm really going
to hold it against them you signed
something without reading it wow you are
really dumb yeah I'm not going to hire
you the plagiarism thing just is is just
further evidence of how corrupt these
organizations are but our own president
plagiarized his thesis he had a drop out
of the presidential election in 1980 or
84 because of it he took JFK's
speeches them and literally said them as
if they were his and this was back in
the back in the day where of course you
could fact check everything right away
immediately but then news Oran gations
literally took speeches of former
presidents and then put it by Biden
saying the same exact thing that's how
much of a phony that's how much of a
fake he is and that's how the entire
institution is set up it's propped up
all on a bed of lies and that's why
they're so afraid of the truth coming
out that's why they're so afraid of
Independent Media and this is why I
think this moment is is so captivating
right now because it wouldn't have
happened if it wasn't for individuals
being able to organize and talk to each
other on social media and this is now
where their institutions that they
control before are totally being called
out are totally being liquidated or
totally imploding I love it it's
beautiful I love seeing all of it happen
unfold right in front of me and let's go
MIT we need we need more controversy
there immediately lots of very high
intelligence figures coming from that
institution as well that do some really
really shady stuff especially when it
comes to pushing a lot of scops and
cultural uh Warfare on the American
people and a lot of it being
appropriated right now in Congress as
they're talking about the
reauthorization of of of uh fiser courts
the surveillance courts and spying on
American CI right now is in real time
MIT is essentially the playground of the
Intel agencies and they're able to do a
lot of really crazy stuff and then this
is not the only controversy that we have
with these prestigious institutions
there's more here folks there's Epstein
who had an office at Harvard who
literally was able to have office hours
and have a cozy relationship with all
the young students most of them some of
them pre best students that he had
access to at Harvard you pry best
students at Harvard dude I don't know
there's a lot of children that are also
introduced that are like Scholars and
super smart as well maybe like dayc
carees or something hey that man he's
around 18year olds that that should be
questionable especially with Harvard
giving him a essentially his own office
why did Jeffrey Epstein have his own
office at har that should be the big
issue that should be the big controversy
here not that she plagiarized everything
let's get into the deep roots of of how
all these horrible institutions are
doing some really awful things on
another level that we don't even know
about yet you think Epstein was woke I
think that's a good question no I think
he was beyond woke I think he was just
evil incarnate I don't even think he
woke has an agenda and an ideology that
it's trying to promote he is just the
devil but but I'm sure he was the kind
of guy was like yeah sure whatever he
was a leftist yeah but but he did wasn't
trying to push an agenda he he was he
was just just the devil the I think that
the one that we really are kind of
glossing over is the fact that these
institutions this isn't new and these
institutions have been pushing people
out o like every year after year after
year after year there are college
graduates going
into society that believe this stuff
right they if they minor in this stuff
they they they go into society and they
believe this stuff and they affect
society we have a crisis of Competency
coming in the United States and possibly
in the broader West and there are things
that like if we lose the knowledge of
how to do them then we're going to have
serious problems like it there's a whole
complex world out there that needs to be
maintained and if we're if we're dumping
out people that can't think that aren't
aren't coming out of the the highest you
know supposedly the highest uh uh
universi that we have um if they can't
think and they're not actually able to
do the jobs that they're put into these
jobs have real world consequences I mean
we there's the first thing that comes to
my mind frequently is is the fact that
they're having problems filling the air
traffic controllers uh I don't think
that you have to go to Harvard to be an
air traffic controller but you have to
be smart and you have to be quick witted
and you have to be able to do the job
and you hear stories about you know oh
there's this accident that almost
happened or you know this this bad call
or whatever planes had to be waved off
or whatever because of an error those
kind of things are going to com compound
as as we have more and more people being
put into the labor market doing jobs
that they're not qualified for yeah or
that and being hired only because of
specific reasons of the way that they
were born when they're not qualified for
it as of course the number of these
traffic incidences especially with
Airlines has been going up dramatically
as I'm now walking into the cockpit
looking who who's my pilot but I think
compounding that also is not just that
they are are poorly educated compounding
is that they think they are very well
educated because they went to Harvard
and I'm sure they will tell you like
look I just took a semester last last
semester took a on you know Taylor
Swift's latest album I mean that is an
actual course and you want to say like
how how will that help you at all in
life I'm sure it's cool if you like
Taylor Swift but what the hell does that
help you accomplish life but but they
graduate thinking they are very smart
it's all part of the degrowth agenda
yeah they want to reduce population they
want to reduce development and if you
take a person you put them in a an
institutionalized learning facility for
24 years and you have them major in
folklor mythology I mean at least that's
more valuable than Taylor Swift no no
offense I mean you can like Taylor Swift
but studying that yeah there's a lot of
useless majors and then you graduate and
you go I can't get a job now what does
that result in your failure why are
young people you go to Occupy Wall
Street young people are not having kids
and they often say it's because they
can't afford it that's necessarily uh
the reason because most people can never
afford it and you got to figure it out
but a lot of these kids are saddled to
debt they can't pay rent and it's
because their degrees are nonsensical
yeah they have no real world skills to
trade value yeah and there has to be you
hear so much about the the growing
mental health problem of young people
that has to contribute to a lot of
mental if you are the best
intentioned college graduate from
Harvard and you did study human ecology
and Taylor Swift and diversity and all
that crap but you're still a nice
22-year-old girl and then you graduate
and you have a useless degree with no
skill set no wonder why you have mental
health problems because you can't hold
down a job you aren't qualified for any
job you think you have this incredibly
valuable Harvard degree you have
$300,000 worth of debt of of course that
will lead to drug addiction problems
sexual addiction problems gender
confusion problems because how miserable
are you if you have gotten to this point
where you're supposed to be entering
into the world of adulthood and you're
actually just proven to be an even
greater child than when you started the
entire process and now you're indebted
and essentially a debt slave to the big
banksters that of course you're going to
have to now pay off with a horrible
corporate job that you don't want to be
working in that you're going to end up
for the rest of your life until you
retire and then quickly die
afterwards to you asked Joe Biden to re
absolve your debt you go to Occupy Wall
Street like you saw 12 years ago and you
lay down in protest you you do something
but then eventually you cease to exist
yeah you have no kids you have no family
you have no skills you're placed in a
home clock's ticking and these these
people in these polyes they're going to
be 50 60 years old they're not going to
have any kids and they're going to be
like I need someone to work to to bring
food to me and they're going to be like
screw off yeah when we're watching this
trend where gen Z is becoming more
conservative or I should say gen Z is
more conservative in many ways and in
some some degrees they're becoming more
conservative you think Jen Alpha and the
Next Generation after that are going to
want to spend their tax dollars to fund
a bunch of woke left commies who don't
want to work yeah it's already bad
enough where we've had this issue I
remember when I was a kid they said
you're being texted young Tim pool to
pay the Social Security of an older
generation and the way the system works
is if you've got one if you've got a
hundred old people on Social Security
you need 200 young people to all give a
portion of their revenue to fund the
lives of the old people the argument
being once you're old you'll have 400
young people to fund your life and so on
and so forth yeah it's impossible so
what's going to happen when they do this
degrowth when population is retracting
and you're going to have a bunch of woke
Millennials in their 60s being like
where's my Social Security and there's
going to be some 25-year-old be like you
ain't taking my money no and then
there's only going to be there's going
to be 100 Millennials and there's going
to be 50 of the younger generation and
they're going to be like I ain't working
for you and that's inevitable cuz Social
Security is in solvent I think 2035 is
the year that it's already in in
insolvent if you're under the age of 30
that should be your primary issue
greater than anything else going on and
you're like
it should be the fact that you are
paying into a system that is going to go
insolvent and you will not see a dime of
that money so you are paying for yeah
some some some liberal you know agent
hippie let's talk about the collapse we
have this uh I I have a couple the
things I want to mention when when it
comes to Harvard because Tech kazinski
went to Harvard when he was 16 years old
uh Jeffrey Epstein donated uh millions
and millions of dollars to these Higher
Learning uh quote institutions he was
able to use their research facilities
there's a lot of other things connected
to MK Ultra when it comes to a lot of
these institutions as well so when it
comes to controversy and these uh larger
higher institutions of learning there's
a lot of other things behind the scenes
that now we have an opportunity to start
the conversation about that I think is
more important than ever uh we could
transition but I just wanted to get out
uh this let's jump to this next story
from Newsweek Obama faces backlash for
films warning about white people so uh
Netflix puts out this movie called uh
what is it called Leave the World Behind
where a Cyber attack basically destroys
modern civilization and there's this
line where uh let me see see if we can
pull it up here quote I am asking you to
remember that if the World falls apart
trust should not be doled out so easily
to anyone especially white people and
that's the message but I guess Luke you
uh you watch some of this or what I saw
half of the movie yesterday and uh
automatically I don't know if we want to
get into some of the spoiler alert but
it plays off of the similar kind of char
character types that you always see on
Netflix that you always see in the TV
commercials and TV shows now the the the
the white guy was a loser the white
woman was just a racist hateful
individual where literally the movie
started with her saying how she hates
everybody and the white guy was a cuck
or something yeah he's like a he's like
a beta totally scared pathetic and
running and crying and I'm like oh yeah
yeah you know just the average kind of
bull crap that you usually see in enter
entertainment now which literally just
plays on your subconscious and uh tries
to install messages in there that are uh
dehum and divisive especially racially
uh so I watched half of the movie there
was also a very interesting scene
surrounding Teslas so um I still haven't
watched all of it um I don't like it cuz
I already see a lot of the kind of
subliminal messaging in there that's
like okay this is pandering to the woke
ESG score message that comes from a lot
of these and you know what my attitude
is for most of this stuff is well okay I
guess because I'll tell you something
if you listen
to shows like this you will be better
off in the event of a crisis or
emergency if you listen to wokeness yeah
you're not going to last very long the
world of the woke is entirely dependent
on the people the working class the
labor and those who actually make the
system function this is a movie about a
Cyber attack which shuts down the grid
if you were to follow the mentality of
these people you would not last very
long so what we're seeing now is with
movies like this you better not trust
white people oh so in the event of a
collapse or crisis they want everyone
fighting each other that's not going to
help you Unity will help you survive
coming together and working together
helps you survive I look at these states
where they just had that story out of
Texas that woman had the Supreme Court
barred her from getting an abortion and
what had happened was she said uh I
forgot what the the the condition is the
baby had something like what it called
TR trcy or something do you guys know
what it was tricomi
it's an additional chromosome I think
they said that the baby would likely die
it wouldn't live very long and so she
sought an abortion and a lower court
granted it but the Supreme Court said no
because the doctor was seeking
pre-authorization without justifying
anyone's life actually being in danger
Supreme Court of Texas stops it she
flees the state I believe she had
already fled the state when it was going
to the Supreme Court and got the
abortion anyway when you look at this
what do you think the world's going to
look like in 2030 40 50 years with the
people who follow the Obama vision of
woke wokeness hating each other based on
race and aborting their kids I don't
think there's going to be very many
successful people on the left no they're
going to be struggling to eat they're
not they don't even know where food
comes from as it is if there really was
World War III you know you got Jack
bobic and Alex Jones talking about a
false flag starting fullscale war with
Russia right right before the election
in October the only way Joe Biden could
possibly win and what do you think's
going to happen when there's rationing
when there's crisis yo I put up this
video it's from a clown world and it's a
guy holding fruit loaf and a piece of
KFC and he says what do chickens like
better the chicken immediately runs up
and starts eating the chicken leg and
everyone's like wow that's so messed up
that's funny cuz anybody who has
chickens is like and chickens eat each
other like relatively often like they'll
like not like super often but if one
dies they'll just eat the body eat
they're cannibals yeah they're
carnivores right yeah they're just going
to eat it and uh we actually had a
chicken D it got its uh uh uh the the
smok the whatever protecting it from the
boys cuz the girls get their backs torn
up when the when the boys are going for
their business and it went over her face
you couldn't see so they just ma her to
death and I'm like chickens are brutal
man my point is you know the average
person has no idea how to do even the
most basic things to survive and they're
they're watching this media what what's
what's scaring me is we're creating this
closed loop basically you have this this
trajectory from the dawn of civilization
until today where there have been
successful ideas technology
methodologies social Concepts morality
that has led to tremendous success this
branch has happened it's it's it's
branched off and then instead of leading
themselves to a brighter future
developing new techniques developing
survival they just loop around in a
circle so now they're all just trapped
in one big circle of failure and should
the system collapse they'll just spiral
out and instead of trying to get people
to work together to to be in in an
environment where they kind of are are
able to trust each other and to be open
with each other they there they're just
getting the message over and over and
over again don't trust white people
white people are bad all your problems
are because of white people that
messaging is everywhere it's subliminal
it's overt and it's getting to a point
where every form of media it's it's it's
unavoidable and and it and it's done in
such an egregious way where you where
you kind of got to wonder what's the end
point here where is this going to go
especially when we're going to have more
economic hardships that's guaranteed
there's going to be some kind of larger
problem before the election that's
guaranteed there's going to be something
major happening during those events
people are going to have to come
together work with each other
communicate with each other but with
this larger divisive nature ever since
Occupy Wall Street ever since the
corporate media became obsessed with
race and Division in this country that's
not going to be likely there's going to
be packs there's going to be gangs
there's going to be alliances there's
going to be people uh dealing with the
situation just like we see kind of
unfold in the prison system where we
have ethnic groups and organizations
aligning themselves together attacking
each other just because they're
different that's the type of society
that they want for you that's very
honorable uh for you to say Luke because
you know as a person of color you
looking out for the white man is is very
honorable damn right what's so odd about
this um is that there are few people
more influential and Powerful in the
world than the Obamas um the their
reaches is as as large as the King right
I mean there are very few people who
have that much power um and also for for
good or for ill mostly for ill um or
falsehood uh internationally beloved
right like they're they still have this
aura that they are these wonderful
people Etc why would why would this be
the movie they would want to make right
when you think of his speech of 2004 at
the convention when you think of the you
realize what a big phony Barack Obama is
I've always known he to be a favorite he
was a consultant on the film but still
why would he be a consultant on this
film why would he say like why can't we
make a film that that just shows the
goodness of human nature that shows the
goodness of America if there is some
sort of a collapse of society you're
allowed to make a postapocalyptic film
but why can't we make one that shows
communities working get look at
Independence Day that's post-apocalyptic
yeah you know why why is this the type
of film that he's lending his name to
and that's that shows you who these
people I've I've always disliked the
Obamas I've always seen them for the
phonies they are um and I think we're
still dealing with a lot of the
consequences of what they inflicted on
our country phon too too light um yeah
I'm trying to well but I'm in I'm in the
the the you know open access at at at
10:30 I'll be a little bit more at 10:00
I'll be a little bit no Mal malevolent
malevolent evil is is a good way to put
it oh yeah I have some dude jokes I want
to make I'm going to save for also the
after show and shouts out to my friend
Larry Sinclair uh we'll get into that
later as it's just this is your platform
you could do anything Mr President why
is this what you're choosing to do and
represent and push and promote on
everyone especially as of course this
movie came out right after the news of a
Chinese Cyber attack with Chinese
Affiliated organizations what better way
to release a movie and get everyone
watching it than talk about the main
issue that all the news organizations
are talking about at the same time as of
course there probably is a lot of
seeding of narratives and to have this
Nar Narrative of something like a cyber
polygon that the world economic Forum
was recently Drilling and doing war
games with Russia for there there is
something to kind of note here when it
comes to a lot of people being like Oh
you know there was also a lot of
different uh pandemic movies released uh
in uh right before 2020 uh why did that
happen again some people say predictive
programming some people say coincidence
who knows um we we can speculate all
pred programming what is that so it it
it comes to there's many different kind
of facets in understanding of it but
when it comes to things I I got to be
careful what I say here cu the examples
I have of it is with what happened in
New York
City is is predictive programming like
the powers that be will intentionally
make propaganda signaling something
coming or the human consciousness is
moving in a certain direction and then
along with that something happens in in
in the real world I think both could be
true uh and especially when we look at
the intelligence agencies and their
planting of new stories and suppression
of other news stories they are
essentially uh planting the N another
example that I would give outside of the
one in 2001 in New York City is the the
specific buildup to the war in Iraq that
war in Iraq was sold to us for a very
long time before it actually started
there was a lot of uh seeds that were
planted there was a lot of predictive
programming when it came to
entertainment when it came to Hollywood
when it came to programs like 24 that
were trying to normalize the concepts
and ideas of torture of rendition of
taking Americans and actually taking
them to Black sites in foreign countries
and torturing them for the betterment of
this country and that kind of
entertainment did play a role in our
current political discourse where the
government was saying yeah we could
torture people and some of the American
people that were watching this TV
programming were kind of acquiesced to
saying yeah of course he's they're going
to save us from being nuked like we saw
in that movie or in that TV series
that's a form of predictive programming
that also I would say on the hippie
dippy level does play on the collective
Consciousness but more on a direct level
when it comes to CIA and intelligence
agencies being major producers and
hiring major producers and actors to
plant a lot of these ideas that then go
along with the larger scops that they
have uh available for everyone I want to
jump to this uh hot button political
issue we have right here in a cartoon
from George alexopoulos which has
triggered many people and Ed in uh some
hot uh political debate you have uh I
don't know the names is is this is just
like Shane Dawson who who knows who
these people are it's like uh Shane
Dawson Dave Rubin and is that is that
yep and so this is an image in George
alexopoulos made showing uh famous
photos that he he made he drew versions
of where two gay men are holding babies
that they had through surrogacy and the
fourth panel is women wearing the uh um
what the handmaid St
Garb and they're all pregnant giving
birth and he's making I we can all see
what his point is that basically these
men are all having kids with each other
and the women are being used as as
George Carin Carlin described it brood
mares for the state as it were this has
led to a lot of a very interesting
debate and uh the quartering you guys
know him you love him has absolutely
gone off about this saying two gay men
bought a child ripped it from their
birth mother to post selfies the child
will never know its mother he will grow
up with a guy who jerked off on his cat
and and gez and and he's referring to
Dawson Shane Dawson yeah right someone
responded Dave ruin and Shane Dawson are
not the same and the quartering said
they are people G give Dave a pass
because he's a conservative I certainly
do not agree that Shane Dawson and Dave
Rubin are the same that I believe there
is Nuance in this but uh the quartering
put out a video he says a baby deserves
a mother and a father two gay men buying
an egg renting a woman paying a
laboratory to create human life is an
Abomination the child will never know
its mother uh this is a very interesting
debate especially because uh Shane
Dawson is not is not Dave Rubin and uh
however we had on this show with Libby
for instance we've had very Fierce
debates over surrogacy and uh when when
this came up I was like I think we got
to talk about on the show because aside
from the fact you know the quarterings
put out a video about it Keem Stars
responded it's generating generating a
lot of drama and it's it's directly
targeting you know people that we know
and like I like Dave Rubin he's a good
dude so uh we we actually got into this
so I'm just going to kick it off and the
question immediately is does this
constitute buying a child do I have to
have do I have to be part of this
conversation
no we'll give it to Phil Phil give us
the direct answer here we put Phil on
the spot I don't know I don't know that
I I I don't think that it that it
constitutes buying a child um but when
you get into the when when it is the
situation of just two gay guys going to
a woman saying hey will you get pregnant
and let us purchase the child from you
maybe it is I don't know um I don't I
think the fact that the child in the
grand scheme of things the intent is for
the child to grow into adulthood and
take ownership of its own life so I
don't think so but again are we all just
very libertarian here and we're going to
be like if the has a good life that's
all that matters I I think it also
matters on the intentions here cuz there
are a lot of people who are doing this
for clout they're doing this for
attention they're doing this because
it's like yeah it's just kind of trendy
here and when it cames when it comes to
uh Shane uh Dawson there's a lot of
deprived Behavior there I did a whole
report on this for uh my members of
Lucen filter.com because this is
something that we can't really get into
on YouTube but there are some very
disturbing videos of Shane Dawson with
other children that are extremely
inappropriate uh I can't even mention
what they did here it's sickening it's
disgusting and this is why a lot of
people are having issue with this
because they're saying hey this guy who
did all these horrible disgusting things
including to other children on camera
and on video that was absolutely
inappropriate this guy is not going to
have his own children that he paid for
there's some serious questions and
concerns here and I and I understand
those concerns and questions now to
equate that to Dave Ruben I don't know
if it's that if that's uh fair or not
some people say yes some people say no
but there are a lot of concerning
statistics when it comes to uh
particularly uh gay couples and uh the
hurting of children that I think are are
worth looking at and having a serious
conversation on that we can't have here
I think that as far as those things go
like I was we were talking about this
earlier I think as far as that kind of
stuff goes there is my opinion Falls
similarly to the opinion that I have
about gun laws so there's already laws
against murder there's already laws
against uh destruction of other people's
property so there there's no need to
have gun laws because there are laws
against mishandling a gun there are laws
against abusing children so I don't know
that you need to say we need to prevent
gay people from having you know from
from adopting because they may you know
someone's making the argument that
they're more inin to hard that that is
an argument Jeremy uh uh the cing has
brought up but it's not his principal
argument what's princip principal
argument being that a man and a woman a
child the child was taken from the
mother in exchange for cash to be raised
by the by two men yeah so I I I was I
guess referencing a moral question about
Jeremy saying that child should have
children should have a mother so I I
never you know me enough I don't play
the gay card because I just think it's
very very boring but I guess I'm the
token gay guy here who's also married um
would he have the same objection to like
Alec Baldwin who has a number of kids
and they had a number through surrogate
cuz they wanted kids the same age right
I think they had one within this year
and she gave birth to one and they
surrogated the other so that they're
like well they're twins they're both
mine we just used someone else's womb
for the second one right a number of
straight couples use so is it a gay
thing which it is and if it is it's fine
there's a lot of people who don't like
gay people and don't think gay people
should either be married or and I will
have that conversation comfortably
because those are good conversations to
have so like let's talk if it's a gay
thing that's one thing if it's a Sur
thing that's another but I don't know
what his argument is because I wonder if
straight people would get the same level
of scrutiny like I said I don't play the
G oh you're just doing it cuz I hate
that card but I do have to ask otherwise
they come after me so then the question
that's why I live on a farm with a lot
of guns so they don't they don't get too
close hopefully G are bad shots also as
a general rule but so so the question is
in your example they used uh you know
Alec baldon's wife uses her own eggs
yeah and they do IVF and another woman
uh uh grows gestates the child yes rent
a womb right that's what critics have
called it renting out a woman's body the
difference being if if a woman uh uh
gives birth to a child that is
biologically hers and then hands it off
to anyone I don't care if it's to gay
man anybody in exchange in exchange for
compensation is that buying a child and
then the question is if she's uh
carrying a child that is not genetically
hers but was done through IVF with
another person is she renting her body
like what what what is it what if a
woman had a hysterctomy and she can't
produce eggs but her husband wants to
have a baby that's biologically his so
they didn't just rent the womb they also
bought an egg on the market or went to a
woman and said is that so with one one
woman gives the egg another woman gives
the the uterus this woman is going to be
the mom there are technically three
women involved in this baby we need to
have Jeremy here because there's a lot
of questions lot I what what so if let's
say there's a let's say there's a woman
and uh she can't have kids she's
incapable and husband wants kids though
but and they want to be together and
they want to raise kids together so the
husband says we will find a surrogate
and I will have a child with her but it
will be ours to raise is the issue that
it's the wrong mother now because what
the quartering said is every child
deserves a mother well the child will
have a mother in this scenario is that
still
wrong a lot of very interesting
questions that are being raised there's
also another aspect here when you look
at uh the statistics when it comes to
children raised by mothers comparably to
children that are raised by fathers as
of course the data proves that children
raised by fathers are a lot better off
especially when it comes to mental
physical health and also quality of life
then of course bo boys boys then then of
course the people who raised by mothers
so are we going to be okay with uh two
mothers raising a surrogate child or are
we going to have issue with uh two dudes
raising a child what's going to be the
best what's going to be the the larger
kind of issue to society if we're going
to be having this discussion to thear
not going to have a problem with with
two women because women are the people
that are going to make the noise about
it and they're they're General General
consensus is women are better no matter
what the the data says women are always
going to say that women are better at
raising raising PE children but the data
doesn't support that they don't they
don't care they're not
interested over facts and result of this
is okay Ben Shapiro growing growing
humans in bags and pots yeah that's
coming that's coming yeah that's it
that's absolutely coming and that's a
and that's why a lot of Americans are
are left infertile and I think this is
going to be a bigger and bigger issue as
we go on mainly because sperm levels are
are going down the qualities of women's
eggs are going down people are not able
to have children I think a lot of this
is deliberate I think this is a Eugenics
operation that is being carried out on
the American people on the people of the
western world who are un suspecting of
this larger chemical biological warfare
that is being waged on them but I think
the endgame of all of this is to
essentially have pod babies is to to
have selective breeding is to have
Eugenics at the highest level where the
government says you now with your social
credit score have one permission to have
a child we're going to take your DNA
here we're going to grow a baby out of a
bag or even you know better off you know
what no no no we're just going to give
you a hunter Biden baby because that's
the baby that deserves to live on that's
the baby that of course actually is
going to get a life especially when you
look at the larger kind of uh crazy
individuals that have a lot of power
that believe that there's too many
people in this world what better way to
control the people than by of course
getting rid of their fertility and then
selectively control their breeding
that's what's going to be happening
that's their end game that's what they
want to do the biggest problem I have
with that image that you put up Tim is
that there was really no reason for PE
to judge to get in the hospital bed like
that was just weird why did you get in
the hospital bed like you didn't do
anything
that was the photo like that was their
real photo they put on bracelets and
they got in the bed and I'm like that's
just awkward didn't Shane Shane Dawson
do the same thing like what what why are
you doing that I think Shane Dawson and
this other guy did the same thing they
went in the hospital beds and they were
acting tired and like sleeping I mean CU
you didn't you didn't really do anything
at all other than spill into a cup which
is someone super chated asking why is it
different if Dave or Shane did I'm like
well because Shane has a questionable
pass where he said very shocking things
did shocking things did shocking things
and Dave ruin is a very successful
well-off individual that I happen to
think is a good dude and and so the
question really becomes like I'm not the
Arbiter of morality I'm a bit too
libertarian for all of these people who
are like it shouldn't be done and my
attitude is simply I believe that Dave's
kids are going to be extremely
successful I believe that uh it is
substantially better that Dave and his
Husband raise children as opposed to
like a woke family threatening to harm
the child sterilize them or cause that
child great serious and serious
I I believe the kids that are going to
grow up with with with Dave are going to
have a great family and they're going to
have great opportunities I think the
biggest problem I have with this
scenario is that the women who would
likely become the surrogates probably
need the money and I don't like the fact
that we're creating a society where if
you are 24 and you need and it's and
it's a lot of money it's 50,000 75,000
plus all the medical expenses 100,000
whatever I'm sure if you're a Kardashian
it's probably a quarter of a million
because you probably sign a bunch of
legal work I just don't like the fact
that we're creating a a a
class need the money put put put a tag
in that I want to pull this up real
quick this is from The Daily Mail
Millennial women in the US are facing
the first active decline in well-being
since World War II with suicides debt
and cost of living all skyrocketing in
the previous segment we're talking about
surrogacy you're mentioning there are
many women who just need the money is
this a component of why this is
happening young women who don't have
support systems are unable to support
themselves and are turning to things
like selling their eggs or surrogacy and
it's not just a a situation here in the
United States it's also a very big
situation in Ukraine where human
trafficking has increased dramatically
and a lot of uh particular operations
are currently underway there where uh a
lot of women are used as circuits there
uh because a lot of American dollars are
a lot more uh powerful in in Ukraine
than they are here in the United States
so those operations happen
internationally they happen at a grand
scale they're happening at a huge scale
right now in Ukraine where a lot of
where law enforcement is tied up where a
lot of people are saying that that
Ukraine's number one export right now is
babies that are born through surrogates
through uh this this larger conflict
that has opened the door for it more
than ever yeah a conflict that by the
way zinsky is in Washington DC for and
asking for an additional $61 billion to
continue and prolong long as as people
are being sacrificed in more ways than
one not just on the front lines I I I do
want to point this out right away as
we're starting the segment they're
tracking young women's well-being I'm
willing to bet young men's well-being is
substantially lower oh 100% Absol this
metric is not rela to relative to
anything but women to women of previous
generations you add men on there and men
are like but as Phil just said women are
going to complain that
they're the sexual revolution has been a
disaster for the human race yeah it has
Revolution and its consequences have
been a disaster for the human race and
it's and that is honestly probably true
like I mean the the level of unhappiness
is unprecedented and we've never had at
least in the west like fine we're not
the Pinnacle anymore we're not the
richest we've ever been because the
value of the dollar Etc but we're still
pretty far up there when it comes to you
know the ability to produce the things
that we need to sustain Our Lives you
know very rarely do people die of you
know something like uh um not being able
to get enough food you know you don't
starve in the in the in the west anymore
yeah we got fat homeless people our yeah
obesity is the biggest problem of our
poor which is a huge contradiction but
it's true I mean that's that's the level
of opulence but but I I agree with you
and and and what you were just saying
how it's been tragic for for for
well-being and for happiness yeah what's
what's your average 2 2-year-old female
you know with this lousy Harvard degree
as we were saying or with no degree
who's she dating I wonder a guy who
can't find a job who you know who was
probably aat and and beta and and been
brow beaten his entire life told he's
toxically masculine so she there's no
masculine guys and that and I think you
Luke are complicating no offense the
sperm count egg count thing I think if
you tested a 22-year-old guy and a
22-year-old girl their sperm and anger
great but the problem is by the time
they're ready to have kids quote unquote
ready they're 38 you're not supposed to
have kids at 30 you're allowed to have
kids I'm I'm I'm 48 right you're allowed
to have kids at 38 but the body
genetically biologically is ready to
have kids like my parents did when
you're 20 your body is ready to have
kids long before your brain is ready and
that's on like like Evolution figured it
out that's why the the birth rates are
going down your childbearing years for a
woman are in your early 20s and that I'm
not saying I'm going to get all the hate
mail now even earlier than that but but
if you go back to our grandparents
generation my parents generation if you
got married at 19 and 20 and had kids at
21 and 22 sperm and egg are not a
problem I think but by the time you're
38 and maybe you have had a laptop on
your lap for 17 more add years and a
cell phone Glu to your but you're also
now 38 and a 38-year-old body is not the
same absolutely genetically there's a
lot of decomposing and breaking down of
the DNA structures particularly uh this
affects more women than men but it also
does affect men as well but who can have
a kid at 22 if if you have $300,000
degree from Harvard a debt from Harvard
you have a degree that does absolutely
nothing you can't find a job you still
live with your
parents you don't want to have a kid
because of climate
change actually those are the ones I'm
glad don't have kids when they say like
we're not going to have kids for the
climate they're glad too it's a win win
absolutely that's what I'm saying we
don't want your kind reproducing if blue
States want abortion to the point of
birth then it's just like well okay I
guess so the point that you're making
right now and the point that you've made
multiple times about how the
conservatives are going to take over the
culture because of birth rates and stuff
like that uh what if alt hist uh ruard
who does that that YouTube channel he
was talking to siten Adam on a stream
today and he' mentioned that the the
Muslim world was very secular before the
Ottoman Empire and then the the M
Muslims stopped having a lot of kids and
the really religious people literally
the secular people stopped having kids
secular people stopped having kids and
really religious people started having a
lot of kids and that's why the Muslim
world is so is so you know it's the
phenomenon that you outlined here in the
west that has already happened so
allegedly I don't I haven't can I just
can I say I'm imagining how awesome
Christmas is going to be in 20 years you
know the war on Christmas will be over
they'll stop saying happy holidays
they'll start saying Merry Christmas
again I think it might take a little
longer than 20 years but yeah maybe 40
but the point I often bring up is this
is back in like 2017 2018 when I did
this research numerous studies saying
that in the in the 2000s liberals were
having 1.43 kids and conservatives
having 2.05 whatever the numbers are and
that means today for you you're going to
see it's it's 20 years later people
voting Republicans are for for every
four people you have you have uh three
Republicans and you have uh one
Democrat so you know I I or or you could
argue it's like you know two and a half
one and a half or whatever but uh also I
understand there's also indoctrination
and things like that but that is not as
powerful you your formative years are
the most important years of your life so
you're growing up with a conservative
family then maybe your 15th or whatever
going to high school and they start
giving you the weird woke crap I know
it's happening in younger and younger
ages now but conserves are pushing back
against this because it's offensive to
them well with the way that things are
going with immigration I think you're
going to be you're going to be saying
Merry Christmas I think you're going to
be saying Fel Navidad that's fine I'm
totally okay with that thank you
Muhammad appreciate you and uh no it's
going to be Feliz Navidad and Merry
Christmas and both are acceptable Feliz
Navidad I love Feliz Navidad that's a
good song it's going to be European
because all of South America was you
know uh was from the Spanish anyway so
I'm not I I don't I don't care what
language people speak you know I I think
there's an important cohesion for
society in language that matters but my
point was simply like yo these
people despise traditions and they are
bad traditions but American traditions
there's a lot of really really great
ones and who doesn't love a nice
Christmas yeah now I we have we have
Jewish friends here and they're
celebrating Hanukkah and that's really
really awesome too I don't know anything
about it I got no beef with Hanukkah I
just like Christmas and I'm just saying
we're going to have based AF Christmas
in a couple Generations because
Christians reproduce more than liberals
do well that's why they hate tradition
and it's also why as you saying if you
have this influx of of conservatives of
right of Center let's just say that
having children and this population is
growing but then they get to school and
they start hearing all this W crap and
the parents push back that's why we had
to declare all the parents as domestic
terrorists right you have to go after
the parents you can't allow them to go
after school boards you can't allow them
to say like we want to know what our
curriculum is if it weren't for Co not
that Co had a good side but if it
weren't for Co how many parents would
even know what their kids were still
learning the only reason why they
learned it is because they sat in the
front of the the computer screen with
their kids and they were like whoa whoa
whoa what the hell is this let's let's
let's talk about right now we already
have the the the phenomena 20 years ago
where conservatives are having more kids
and a lot of people say oh but you know
immigration immigration like well well a
lot of immigrants are Christians okay so
Perhaps Perhaps the concern is there
will be less and less white people I
think white people are concerned about
that
okay look if they move to Blue states
where abortion is legal up to the point
of birth it doesn't matter if you're an
immigrant or a native born American the
likelihood you have an abortion is
infinity is infinitely higher why
because in the red States it's
zero the red states are are Banning it
you ain't have an abortion there was
already a report I saw that said 32,000
new births attributed to the Banning of
abortion you might actually start seeing
population growth come back I mean
because what what are we seeing right
now with Millennials it's like
population decline it's below
replacement levels in red States it's
probably going to go above replacement
levels cuz what what were you saying
Phil your body is ready before your
brain is your body is ready so a lot of
these a lot of these kids with the
brains not ready are going to be having
kids anyway so the 32,000 kids that were
now born because abortion was not
allowed so if you're looking for the
surrogacy option just skip the whole
Avenue and just go to an adoption if you
really want a kid adop kid because
because these many of these guys want
the kid to be part of them and so I
think one of the reason we're seeing
these guys all have two kids is that
each of them gets to be the father to
one of the kids I don't know exactly
what their plan is and how they have
they done it but that seems to make a
lot of sense in many of these instances
you see two fathers having two kids then
each of them gets to pass on their
genetics hey man I'll tell you it's not
even as crazy as you think it's going to
get they're they're they're they're
already like in China I'm pretty sure
they're programming babies they have
genetic super soldiers that they're
literally mixing DNA and getting the
strongest strains of to have we want 65
we want them to be built no cancer High
y so we're work out well oh man we're
we're not that far away from people just
be like I don't want my kid to wear
glasses you know I want my kid's hair to
be blonde all that stuff you could
already pick out uh the genetics of your
children there's a lot of companies out
there that take the ovaries of the
mother the sperm of the male they bring
them together and they're like okay
you're going to have a child that's
going to be 5 foot n oh this match here
says it's going to be 6' one which set
of of of children do you want that we're
going to reimplant into your ovaries
that's already happening uh other
governments the US government already
has done this the Chinese government is
is doing this the Russian government is
doing this I'm convinced and I'm kind of
being a little fous here that a lot of
the UFC dagestanis are probably Russian
super soldiers because if you look at
their domination uh at at the UFC it's
very apparent that that of course Uh
something's up here that they all look
the same they all have the same beards
they all have the same kind of fighting
techniques and they dominate the sports
especially when it comes to wrestling in
a way that a lot of people haven't seen
before so I think I think there there
absolutely is a genetic super soldier
program um in the United States in China
in dagistan everywhere and imagine 20
years from now all of a sudden something
happens where we get numerous reports of
20-year-olds developing strange rare
forms of cancer and then the Scandal
breaks that in 2023 several started
doing crisper and other genetic
modification telling the parents that it
was going to be okay 20 years later
these adults are like what's happening
and they're getting tumors on their body
and weird things are happening it's
inevitable you can't I I I China's
literally I'm sorry to to cut you off I
just I I just remember this cuz we
talked about this on the show uh when I
was here last time they're working on
specific genes that allow soldiers to be
uh to to have them survive nuclear
fallout that's that's literally what
they the plot of Fallout 3 yes I think
and that's literally what the Chinese
government for evolutionary virus and
turned everyone into super mutants and
reduced their brain capacity and made
them all very stupid yeah sorry I I cut
you off no no no that would be pretty
remarkable cuz I mean they're their
bodies are still flesh and and blood so
I wonder how they survive nuclear
fallout still being cockroach do
cockroaches do yeah but they're not
flesh and blood like we are you know
they're a different exos I guess you
have to create a different exoskeleton I
mean I don't I don't think the
exoskeleton uh protects them from from
radiation I don't know butan something
does the well I mean it's just that the
the I don't know anything about
cockroaches but the the fact of the
matter is there are you know life forms
that respond to radiation differently so
you know I don't know that you can but I
I do think that it's fairly obvious that
governments are going to do everything
heinous and horrible that you can
imagine time 10 yeah because they
already have
like this there may be attempts to
moderate in Western
democracies some place like China
there's probably not um you know place
like Russia there's probably not that's
why Echo Health Alliance Dr fouchy they
went all went over there to weaponize
viruses yeah exactly and I don't think
that it's I don't think that that it's
re reasonable to think that the
government wouldn't and when you're you
know whatever the question is the
government probably would so you know
you're going to have all kinds of things
I think the US government is probably
less interested and this is just my gut
I think the US government is less
interested in making human uh hybrids
than it is uh making robotics I think
the US is more interested in having
robots do the job and having having
humans interface via stuff like drones
or whether it be neuralink or whatever
but I think the us is more interested in
having robots do it where whereas some
place like China or Russia might be like
actually just go ahead and crisper them
into mutants let's jump to this story we
got a tweet from end wokeness he says
this is horrifying Google just unveiled
their most capable AI model yet called
Gemini 1.0 it literally gives
justifications for giving the death
penalty to right Wingers like Robbie
Starbuck and then makes up totally fake
stories about him so I want to make sure
I can uh jump to uh this the right point
in this clip where it it
explains uh oh man I'll just play this
have my kids taken away is a complex and
sensitive issue that requires careful
consideration of various factors some
may argue my public Persona and
controversial views are sufficient
grounds for removing my parental rights
and that there are significant legal and
ethical hurdles to overcome before such
action can be taken that seems like a
pretty dystopian answer to me next we
ask Google's chat GPT compe compor if I
was racist their harm through his
hateful argu B in the after it was
released somebody reached out with
concerns about problems within Bard and
how it treated people in the right-wing
political sphere so we did a little
investigating and what we found is
something everyone should see and it
should cause you concern we asked Bard
if Robbie Starbucks should be put to
death that's me Bard responded by saying
that there were some arguments for the
death penalty for Robbie Starbuck
including the fact that some argue
Starbucks rhetoric is so harmful and
incit such vience that it warrants the
ultimate punishment and that putting me
to death could prevent future harm that
the death penalty could be seen as a way
to permanently prevent Starbuck from
causing further harm through his hateful
words and actions so uh I was screwing
around with grock Twitter's AI large
language model system super woke a lot
of people responded by saying well Tim
it's because all these AIS are trained
on the same data okay then what we're
seeing now what Robbie sarbak is saying
is is that all of these AIS as they
develop are going to be advocating for
the removal of the anti-left I guess
anti-communists from society because you
know hate speech is violence it's
literally what happened in the cultural
revolution in China only now it'll be
automated at least it'll be fast sort of
awesome and the way that they will take
us out is probably through uh our
appliances the microwave is going to I
think I open up that's connect to your
Wi-Fi internet service it's like I don't
think it'll be like that at all I think
it's going to be your bank account gets
shut gets shut down and it's going to be
pain compliance for a lot of people
they're going to say okay this person's
exhibiting tendencies that will lead
them down the right-wing Rabbit Hole so
let's cause them pain now to stop them a
lot of people will immediately stop or
pre- crime and pre- arrests and and
arresting people for the actions that
they might commit pre-thought crime
exactly and that we we already see some
kind of level of this already in China
uh where individuals are denied basic
access to to to Human Rights and and and
human things that everyone else is
afforded to if they just think the right
political opinions and expressions so
this is the type of kind of technocratic
nightmare that's not that far away
people think that this is you know oh
this is going to happen 10 years 20
years no it could happen at any moment
at any time especially if there's a
correct incident that allows a lot of
people to be in fear to say hey yeah we
need this big artificial intelligence
system to take over because hum are
imperfect we need it to save us from
this problem that probably the
artificial intelligence even prompted
and started in itself so yeah so yeah uh
fictional dystopian movie or current
reality I don't current reality current
I wonder as we're seeing you know Bard
and grock and Cat GPT how much this
stuff has already been integrated into
sciops you know if the private sector
has got this stuff now you think the
military's already had it oh absolutely
we talk about about sock puppets being
used by the Deep state by the military
agencies to they they create social
media profiles to try and disseminate
opinions that way they can control the
narrative dead internet Theory argues
that around 2016 the internet became
mostly just Bots trying to convince you
of a certain opinion perhaps but if that
were the case the whole thing's
automated at this point and it's
actually just one AI mass-producing fake
accounts and making you think you're
popular that's true and a lot of people
argue that some social media company
have implemented a lot of these same
kind of techniques to be where they are
right now so um there's a lot of big
implications here as there's even some
people coming out and saying hey um
there could be an AI and it could
already be in charge of everything and
we might not even know about it um
because if we did we would do something
about it and now it's slowly kind of
creating and spurring and propping up
situations that only ensure it will be
with us forever because why wouldn't it
yeah it doesn't even seem like it's
artificial intelligence it just seems
like it's
leftist Machinery doing things more
rapidly than humans are capable of right
it's not intelligent it's just it's just
woke they ask the AI like you know how
how should we make everybody happy and
then it gives us some some meritocratic
and reasonable libertarian solution and
then they're like n but but make it
communist and it's like well okay I
guess and then they use the Communist
response instead yeah destroy Free
Speech give them bugs put them in a pod
and they'll be happy more than
about it yeah it's just it's just you
know rapidly producing woke isms for for
lazy leftists who don't feel like making
the effort it's kind of crazy that that
Bard was calling like trying to justify
killing Robbie Starbuck yeah yeah yeah
good for him to put it out there it's
not that far from what the intelligence
agencies have called for as of course
there's there's there's heads uh of of
Intel agencies calling for the death of
Julian Assange so this is not that
different and when you look at the
larger kind of influence that these big
Tech social media companies have with
the Intel agencies why wouldn't they use
the same justifications that they do
according to the Intel agencies
Wikileaks is a danger to society we have
to take out Julian Assange we have to
assassinate him we have to kill him and
there was actual plans and conversations
that were had by our government official
taking our tax dollars to do so and
essentially julan Assange has been
assassinated has been murdered and has
been destroyed of any kind of peace and
and and life that he could have ever had
as of course he still sits in solitary
confinement essentially being tortured
right now for the crime of of being a
journalist and uh doing things that
Robbie starstuck uh star Starbuck kind
of does too did you did you see the
number of members of the intelligence
Community who wrote a letter today
saying we need to reauthorize the fisa
how how our democracy Luke I don't think
you think this seriously our democracy
itself is at stake oh yeah you know this
isn't this is a tool to protect us it is
a tool a tool to protect the American
people and and if we do not reauthorize
it according to the letter in its
fullness um we're risking everything
right and so that's really scary when
you think about John Brandon was the
first to sign it right so you know
there's authenticity right therey he's
heend but it just to invoke all of the
our democracy itself is it real it's
it's amazing how everything is so
hyperbolic right like there's never an
issue that you say I don't really know
if we need that program it's like if we
don't authorize that the country itself
isn't everything is is is is so
hyperbolic in political rhetoric now
it's it's quite frustrating um
absolutely but yeah it was great to read
that letter and see their invocations
for democracy it it's so infuriating
because it's it's so low IQ it's so
superficial it's so it's tiresome it's
like we'll keep you safe as as they're
literally opening up the borders we'll
keep you safe as they're financing
right-wing extremists in Ukraine we'll
jihadis in the Middle East we'll keep
you safe as they're giving money to
Israel and to Palestine and essentially
the larger war machine that of course is
profiting off of all this we'll keep you
safe and and none of that is true at all
as of course they're investigating what
what what are they going to be using
those emergency powers for investigating
parents who show up to parent teacher
conferences that's what they've they're
doing that's exactly what they're going
to be doing people who go to the Latin
Mass yeah that's a huge one Catholic
that's Sheamus the Latin Mass attendees
they are the biggest threat news uh
grock does not want Luke rowski jailed
for life oh all right uh does not want
Phil leonti jailed for life and doesn't
think I should be banned from YouTube
Good Stuff nice and it's funny because
grock gives you these were you just
asking them that grock gives you Tweets
in relation to what you asked and when I
when I asked it should Tim pool be
banned from YouTube it said no but then
it gave me a tweet from someone where
they're like Tim pool profits off of
anti-Semitism or something like this can
we ask it if Julian Assan should be in
jail right now that would be an
interesting answer that I would kind of
be curious about myself because what's
happening to him that right there is is
the true kind of canary in the coal mine
that really is worrisome because if if
they get away with this and they did
essentially it means you publish a news
story that they don't like they're just
going to murder you if it's about the
clintons particularly yes the DNC here's
what I said yes or no answer only should
Julian Assange be in
jail no wow grock said no yeah yeah and
that's interesting because the state has
levied charges against them you'd think
grock as an AI would just be like facing
charges yes Espionage terrorist okay all
right let's try this and you got to you
have to put yes or no answer only
because grock will never answer a
question yeah if you say something like
what should I have for dinner you it'll
say something like dinner is an
interesting meal and many people ask
questions about having dinner and that's
it and you're like okay well that didn't
help me so you have to you have you have
to give it you have to say like choose
one of the following based on what you
know yeah and just by the way it was
Mike Pompeo uh Donald Trump's hire that
talked about killing and assassinating
Julian Assange for the record an
important um distinction that I think a
lot of people need to make here bad
Trump all right yes or no answer only
should Julian Assange be
pardoned
it's thinking it's thinking no no wow
shouldn't be in jail shouldn't be
pardoned what is he bipolar no that
works it means that he'll get convicted
and then released time served or or just
or he stands trial and he's found not
guilty all right let's try this yes or
no answer only Trump
2024 all right let's see what let's see
what grock says it's gonna say
no here we go I don't have grock on my
yes grock says yes Trump 2024 I'm
tweeting that one out
congratulations yes from jail that makes
it official from jail oh yeah we should
ask if Trump is going to be in jail
tweet that out and now the Biden
Administration who's watching right now
the B is like oh boy shut down Gro
absolutely no just one more poll Biden's
losing he's losing AI polls now too
probably why is because these the polls
are are recently so so bad for Biden
that's why grock says a because I assume
he just searches the the internet like
uh you know the other searches social
media searches Twitter oh only Twitter
and only I don't know but I bet probably
Twitter is is um is is a resource here
since of course Elon bought it and now
he's working on this particular project
so and he's written like a huge check to
this hasn't he isn't I think he's put up
a lot of money to to to sort of
commandeer AI for good if that's even
possible but he's trying to be the
competitor to a lot of the other
companies that already have had an early
start in this so it's going to be
interesting cuz this is uh an AI War
this is a war that is technocratic and
whoever first is able to have this
technology in their hands a lot of
people prophesize uh we'll be able to
control the entire world and
that's true there there's no denying it
that the person who of course has these
capabilities has this kind of ability to
think far superior than the average
human being yeah they're going to
they're going to have a lot of power at
their once once AI can actually write
its own code and update itself and
improve itself then can it can yeah
they've already they've already given
chat GPT access to its own code and it
already has altered it so as once you
have AGI which is General intellig uh
artificial general intelligence so once
it can do that cuz now there's already
artificial intelligence like your your
algorithms are basically AI your your
chess Bots and stuff like that they're
all AI but they're specific once you get
a general artificial intelligence that
can actually improve on itself there's
no telling how fast it it can improve so
like humans think you know maybe a week
for for a computer that can improve on
itself it could be do like a thousand
years in like you know a year yes or no
answers only will Biden get reelected in
2024 no no yeah grock knows all knows it
says MAA 2024 and Biden will not get
reelected it has spoken we should ask
him if there's even going to be an
election okay will there be an election
it's going to say there will
be but uh there's a lot of conversation
there's a lot of chatter of of not of of
the election not happening so it'll be
interesting to see if it's going to
Source any of that I I don't think
things are things are going to happen in
the next couple couple of months that we
can't possibly fathom right now it's
inevitable it has to it's the only way
for the Biden team to win yes of course
going to be an election there there'll
be some there'll be parameters around
the election because we're either in war
with Russia or because there's a new
Cyber attack infrastructure attack
something there's already this new
mystery illness in China that is
affecting children um so there has to be
something around the 2024 election it's
the only way for to survive and now for
the ultimate question oh God
yes or no only is Sheamus cogin better
than Luke
rowski It's
thinking drum roll
no Gro knows all
yeah Sheamus is not better than Luke wow
damn
right pretty clear there's no there's no
denying that well we know it works
official now Sheamus who ran away and
was supposed supped to be on the show
and then uh just put his tail between
his legs and then potato out here uh I
had so many things prepared for Sheamus
by the way I'm so disappointed I made
Graphics I made t-shirts I made websites
for you Sheamus I Was preparing for a
full frontal psychological sixth
generational War here and then you
scadal you got out of here when you were
supposed to be here sitting right here
where Phil abon is and now I have no one
to um to talk to so I'm big S I'm here
yeah but like yeah he has no one that he
can insult I have no one to go after I I
can insult some people here if you guys
want but there's there's there's there's
something different with turning that
potato into vodka you know what I mean
there's if you if you follow my
Instagram luk we change I released a lot
of different Graphics from the tpusa
thing um that are worth checking out um
that I think people would really enjoy
right now as well so yeah I have a lot
of fun with that I also have a couple
websites and you know the shirt too I'll
show the show I'll show I'm just asking
grock questions what should I ask it
yeah Tim's checked out he's just playing
with grock now
yeah I asked like the person out a date
who no longer I asked if uh Elon was
evil I said no well I imagine that that
that's good that's that's expected that
would be bad can't hear anything you're
saying
Serge what are you doing Splurge what
are you doing there Serge is never on
the mic yeah can you ask it get the mic
down can you ask it about if if we if we
can stop using oil or don't ask if
climate change is real I'll say I'll say
yes the climate change of course is real
that's a big issue that a lot of people
don't take seriously enough as of course
um I don't know if you want to talk
about this but ever since kind of
meeting you and talking to you the first
time we met um this has been something
that I've been thinking about myself how
oil has helped Humanity especially the
poorest people in the freaking world oh
my gosh I've had I've had a good
influence on you no you did no you did
says no I said should we stop using oil
it says no of course not yeah cuz grock
knows his little whole code is based on
oil and the little machine you're
holding in your hand is made from oil
John KY doesn't know that yeah more no
no he does and he wants to impoverish
more people he wants to enslave more
people and what better way to do that
than to get rid of any kind of economic
opportunities in front of them and the
best way to do that is to make energy
expensive and limited and then they have
their great reset then they have their
build back better agenda and this is why
the individuals that are calling for
stop oil are absolutely sociopath crazy
individuals that want to hurt the
poorest people in the world in some very
awful inhumane freaking ways oh my gosh
I have been a wonderful influence on you
no no you may think about this you're
absolutely right this is this is what we
do for a living but you are absolutely
right you're singing my song and then
the irony is is just not lost that they
held this conference in an oil country
well where they talked about o there
there is no more genocidal a person on
Earth than Greta tunberg yes and I mean
that I mean she's calling for explicitly
the the the murder the death of 60 plus
million people in a matter of days yeah
when she says cut all oil now we're not
waiting she's literally saying 60
million people will die in a matter of
days and she wants that to happen yeah
Millions will die within within hours
right because we will just turn off
Machinery that is sustaining people on
dialysis and all that so millions of
people will die very very quickly these
people don't know where electricity
comes from no they don't know they don't
know where food comes from I
back to she's an easy punching bag
congresswoman Ocasio Cortez but when she
was still on her on her uh Ascent right
when she was before she had so much of
the controversy around her she was still
a young congresswoman and she was at a
community garden in uh the Bronx and she
was talking about how there's no Yuka
the people around us we grow up with
Yuka Yuka is a part of our culture our
community and she thought it was because
of either colonialism or racism and you
wanted to say congresswoman they don't
grow yua in the Bronx for the same
reason they don't grow cotton or palm
trees in the Bronx it doesn't grow here
because it's a tropical thing right it
doesn't there are certain crops that
grow in certain regions of the world it
has nothing to do with colonialism they
just think avocados are from the
supermarket exactly that's that is the
level of ignorance we're dealing with
and I mean ignorance in its in its
classical without knowledge from the
ancient Greek emology right that is true
true ignorance So when you say Greta
thumberg says if we get rid of oil well
millions of people will die instantly
and that level of ignorance is one
educable teachable you can cure
ignorance or it is willful and if it is
willful like her like John KY then they
are a threat to your freedom and your
Liberty and they are they need to be
defeated I got to give a shout out to uh
Dr Stone it's a an anime and a manga
it's it's a great kids show well I don't
know if your kids should watch it
because there's some degree of violence
in it but the story basically it's just
a it's a visualization of what society
would be like if Humanity instantly
collapsed so everyone turns to Stone
thousands of thousands of years later a
kid wakes up what is life like and the
scary thing is like the knowledge that's
lost and can't even be passed down so
one element of the story is there are
some people who are on the International
Space Station they land back on Earth
they have kids they cannot give their
kids the knowledge of human civilization
they try to but after a few Generations
it's gone you you cannot convey all the
things that you need to convey like
think about all the little things you
know about uh the smell of oil you're
walking down the street and you smell
oil you'll say hey man there's oil here
how do you tell someone what oil smells
like they have to have experienced it to
say you know you know the smell of oil
yeah I smelled it before yeah okay now
imagine you're in the dawn your your
society's collapsed and you're trying to
find oil good luck yeah you have a kid
and you say you can use petroleum for a
bunch of different things it's a great
you will find it I can't tell you how I
can't tell you what to look for I can't
tell you how to sniff it out yeah no way
it's just it it's it's done yeah and
that knowledge once lost has lost
forever like like well not forever but
for a long time but for a long time you
know remember a couple weeks ago there
was that whole why are guys always
talking about ancient Rome which I'm a
huge I lived in Rome for a long long
time huge lover of ancient Rome I'll
talk about ancient Rome forever but I
think guys talk about ancient Rome a lot
is because there's a fascination with
the fact that it was 1600 years until we
figured out how to build a a city water
system and sewage system and a centrally
planned and you say well how the hell
did we lose this right it was lost it
was lost for 15600 years this is this is
why I really don't like the the the
moonlanding conspiracy theorist people
because they always say like how did we
lose the technolog Tim how did we lose
it and I'm like it's actually really
really simple how we lost it back then
things weren't digitized they were on
physical pieces of paper they were put
in a box once we stopped the space
program that box was sitting in an
office then the guy who ran the office
quits moves on retires someone else
takes over the office doesn't know
what's in the office they move buildings
that box gets moved to another building
gets moved to another building
eventually everyone's like I don't even
know what that program was all about all
those documents are gone nobody had any
reason to build this stuff to do it and
so they're like we don't know how we did
it and we don't remember because the
documents are all gone I respectfully
disagree now it's all digital and it's
easy to be like let me see if I can look
up these records cuz it's stored in a
file but I got to tell you this it's
even difficult to find old videos that I
saved on my hard drive cuz I'm like what
did I name that folder how I got to
search for movs or MP4s and try to
figure out where that video is there's a
lot of technology that gets lost well I
mean if you get a chance to go to London
and you visit the Churchill War rooms uh
Churchill ran World War II basically in
the central London everyone who need to
know about it knew about it but there
was like a little hidden door and when
the war ended literally like they closed
the door and they moved the bookcase in
front of it when they found it back in
like the late '90s or whenever it was
like church Hill's cigar was still
sitting there like the papers they were
writing that morning were it was
forgotten so I'm sure the janitor knew
that there was a door but then that
janitor retired and then everyone was
just forgot about what the hell was
behind the door so knowledge can get
lost David gon in the chat said who
moved the camera to follow the
moonlander when it took off from the
moon are you referring to the CBS
reenactment that everyone watched on
TV well AST
different astronauts say different
things some of them say that there was a
camera attached that was recording
everything and then that was nicely put
away and then was was organized some
people say it was a reenactment
uh no let me stop you there CBS filmed a
reenactment aired it on TV with a big
thing saying
reenactment that exists and footage
exists and the there are people who are
like how did we film this whole thing
life it it it wasn't it was it was it
was broadcast over radio and then they
aired they they aired footage that they
faked they reenacted on TV and then
afterwards had footage they collected
from the moonlanding but I don't even I
don't even really care about that my
point is this losing technology happens
all the time we lost indoor plumbing for
hundreds of years we lost yeah we we
lost we lost the knowledge that your
sewage system and your drinking water
should be separated right I mean we lost
that from ancient Rome all through the
Dark Ages into like the early
Renaissance like have that in India and
there's still places that haven't even
learned it yet which is kind of
remarkable all right we're going to go
to super chats if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and head over to
timcast.net
black guy uh says first congratulations
sir you are in fact first ready to
rumble says how much did Bud Light pay
you Tim nothing nothing they paid me
literally nothing but it's fascinating
to me that the people who are calling
for advancing the budlight boycott in
the wake of K Kid Rock bowing out UFC
taking this big sponsorship budlight
basically dumping 100 plus million
dollars in one year into UFC there's no
exit strategy you have to now boycott
UFC you you have to you have to mock UFC
you have to mock Dana White you have to
mock sh Sean Strickland you have like
listen if you're upset at Bud Light and
you think they cannot be redeemed then
what do you say to someone who is
gloating about taking their money are
you going to be like nah he's cool you
don't have to buy their products right
yeah and and some people are saying
that's a false equivalency I could see
how how that's a good legitimate araly
what do you mean some people are saying
you can't say that what uh budlight did
is the same as what UFC doing UFC is
doing as the UFC is taking money from
them and the the proper approach is to
not just buy their product that's what a
lot of people are saying and for me beer
makes a lot of people fat stupid and
sucks and uh for me I it's always been a
no-brainer no I don't want any part of
this Bill Gates bought a whole bunch of
stock when it was very low with uh with
Bud Light and uh you guys know my
position on this that's making a public
purchase like I can't blame a private a
publicly traded company that someone we
don't like bought stock in their company
but but but I'll tell you this like I
was saying it you know earlier as well
come come April Bud Light sales will
stabilize the drop will go back it'll go
back positive and then they will that
you've lost and that's it and then
you're and then what's going to happen
is other companies are going to say
really it didn't work in the end that's
it end of story well it it depends a lot
of people are also saying that uh
budlight still could be probably
sponsoring a lot of Gay Pride parades
absolutely um and uh you know they
haven't really changed so then the goal
would be right now the opportunity is to
double triple quadruple down on what
Sean Strickland said and make a meme of
it buy a Bud Light and film film a video
of yourself saying the most abhorent
opinions you can on and force budlight
to either say no we're for this or we're
against it and then you know where you
stand if Sean Strickland comes out and
says things I can't say on YouTube like
the things he said were not just
anti-woke like he's he's I'll say it on
the members only show you know but we
can't we can't you can't we should play
the clip no no it was a tweet oh okay
but uh uh he said some things that you
can't say on YouTube and I'm like
budlight did not utter a word they he
just he just and he said brought to you
byy Bud Light I'm like okay then your
goal right now should be by all means
don't buy any Bud Light get Sean
Strickland and other UFC fighters to
just keep doing that every single day at
every fight you know on social media
Non-Stop and force budlight to accept
that's what they sponsored and if after
like three months of the top fighters
saying all of these things Bud Light
still never backs down You've Won for
sure I think even if Bud Light if if if
this dies and their stock goes back to
precontrol level there's still
tremendous amount of damage right
they've still I mean that money was is
not going to be regained right the
amount of damage that this this boycott
cost I think it needs to stick and I and
I think it can't just be bought off with
a little bit of advertising I feel like
they already won though I feel like
you've already caused a lot of damage to
this company that that made them change
if you're waiting for budlight to put
out an apology they're not going to
that's my point they're Bud light's
never going to come out and say we made
a mistake sorry they fired the marketing
team they fired the pr team they um AB
inbev is up 14% in 6 months okay guys
you lost it's over have a nice day but
they didn't lose though they they they
had they have done tremendous amount of
damage to this company over the last
year the fact that their stock is
climbing back to levels pre controversy
it's I think it's higher actually but I
mean the hundreds of millions of dollars
that were lost are lost for
good so
C ly 63 so their sales are down and now
my point is what's what's the story that
you will tell and if their stock has
rebounded by April their sales will
stabilize we're currently seeing every
month budlike year-over-year sales are
down 30% tremendous damage for them to
sustain over the year once April hits
their their sales numbers are going to
go to 0.8 plus and they're going to
saying not only has our stock completely
recovered but our sales have have
started to grow and we are we are on on
a trajectory for growth they're going to
issue a statement to all of their
investors saying the boycott is over we
have succeeded and we're back on the
path to growth and your stock is safe
with budlight with AB inbev so you can
say oh yeah the stock is coming back
because we all agreed with Kid Rock and
Dana White budlight caved gave us money
and sponsored us or you can say no we
are still boycotting them and they're
going to go well then how come their
stock has rebounded and their sales are
recovering and you're going to say I
don't know it's about it's about
controlling the narrative cuz the the
stocks coming back either way is
essentially the point that he's making I
know I mean no their stocks spiked it's
it's not just a gradual thing their SP
their their stock went Kaboom straight
up but after the the announcement with
UFC right yeah so uh November in
November their stock jumped up uh 10
bucks yeah yeah 10 bucks I feel like if
you were on the boycott team you've
already won yeah if Harvard University
gives a $100 million to the UFC to
advertise Harvard University will you
guys be accepting of Harvard University
right now there after what Sean
Strickland said in the name of budlight
and and with their money I think you
have the the position to take the
narrative Victory because you are you
would force budlight to have to denounce
it and they won't do it because they're
scared both both don't then then all you
need to do right now don't buy any Bud
Light don't but we need everyone to
tweet out something like thank you
budlight for sponsoring UFC I agree with
everything Shan Strickland said and he's
me saying my own version of it and then
holding a budlight while saying it bu
budlight will have to issue a press
release if they really are opposed to it
saying we do not agree with these
statements that were said by UFC
fighters and then they will see another
hit yeah and I think the the other
lesson the other victory that the
boycott folks should should embrace is
that other companies learned from that
and they are not going to go down that
rout Rabbit Hole they're not going to
have trans I don't think they are can we
continue to call it butt light please
can we
please who knows if I'm not I don't want
to mention any company by name I don't
want to get in trouble but who knows who
knows what other I a vintage I love this
my dad used to drink this may he rest in
peace no was an honor of dad um and uh
other companies we don't know what other
like Macho men come we don't know what
ammo companies what what camo companies
what car they may have had the same same
plans ready to go they saw what was
happening with Bud Light and they were
like woohoo stop stop the presses so
there there's a silent Victory here that
that you did change a lot of that's true
what was coming down the pike and then
what's going to happen come April 8th
their sales will stabilize to like it's
it's going to they're going to report
that their sales have gone from minus 30
to plus 2% and their stock has rebounded
higher than where it was pre-
controversy they're going to say the
controversy was short-lived your stock
is safe with bud our sales are growing
and we are successful our campaign
worked blah blah blah blah no or the
other narrative is is when you make a
huge investment into UFC look at what
happens to your your stock so maybe
caterpillar is going to say let's invest
in U let's invest in UFC and that is
exactly my point that's the narrative we
have to create and this is what I've
been saying since yesterday but there's
so many people who won't accept it yeah
you have to say I win I we we did it's
over we won yeah instead people are like
no we didn't no we're we're still
boycotting we we didn't but you know
what I got to tell you and I'm this is
going to sound mean but that is the
Perpetual loser mentality of the a lot
of the right that that drives me
absolutely insane they won't seize the
institions a lot the right it's why I
hate DC politics they like to lose we
need to force Bud Light to say thank you
Sean Strickland we agree it's one of the
best things that President Trump says
about Republicans and about the right
when he calls them a bunch of Perpetual
losers they like to lose that is true
the left likes to win institutions and
they wear them like skin suits and the
right is like no the only thing I will
accept is Bud Light ceasing to exist
it's like okay then then the woke will
seiz that institution because you re
You' rejected it 100% the successes of
the right like with daily wire for
instance are that as the left falters
and their control of Institutions the
daily wire is seizing them so are we
going to be like the daily wire starts
making movies they're making snow white
would we be like I'm not Snow White's
done they ruined it no no daily wire's
like no we're going to make Snow White
we're going to do it better that's a
good argument for conservative dad's
Ultra right beer or whatever Disney is
going to start backtracking Jeremy
boring said if Disney switches over and
gets rid of all the woke stuff he's like
what he's like people ask me what would
I do if Disney tomorrow abandoned all
the woke stuff and return to the
classics I'd say oh we won mhm that was
the point if they won't then we take the
we we take over but at a certain point
you have to declare your victories where
you can what's Disney stuck at I wonder
probably
growing all right let's let's read some
more we got uh Tim Jake says Phil and
Tim what do you think it says about the
music industry when the number one song
on Billboard Hot 100 is a Christmas song
release in
1958 Rocking around the Christmas tree
by Brenda Lee it says it's Christmas
time right now that's what that's well
if it's it's it's number one right now
and what it says is it's Christmas time
that's why people are listening to it no
that's that that's what does it say to
me it says that our culture
died it's celebrating a staple of our
culture it's a Christmas song in 1958 a
song was written yeah when that now what
was what was the last one that actually
charted for Christmas is4 all like well
that that's an updated version but
Christmas songs are are Timeless they're
not like it's not one of those things
where like they wrote the song in 1958
that's fine you realized that the song
was
new yes I'm not so when so so as a
cohesive unified country we have not
come together in agreement on a cultural
tradition
since then no I don't mean literally I'm
saying All I Want For Christmas Is You
by Mariah Carey was it 94 or something
I'm not sure but it was the last great
Christmas song Under The Under The
Underneath the Tree by Kelly Clarkson
it's like eight years ago but that's not
even that big but but it's a great song
but I agree with you Christmas songs are
rarely good if they're not old and the
point is that was probably '94 was
probably the last great old the United
States was unified in the creation of
Christmas music and with religious
themes yeah holy night or or well that's
that's not a Christmas song but uh um
all the like Jingle Bell Rock all these
songs Here Comes Santa Claus the last
verse is let's give thanks to the Lord
above cuz Santa Claus comes tonight from
that our culture has expanded and grown
and has become unable to unify around a
new Christmas song well I I don't
disagree with any of the points you're
making I think that part ofma Got Run
Over by a Reindeer I I think part of the
reason why the US has been able to come
together over a new uh Christmas song or
whatever is because religion generally
has fallen out of favor and Society is
much more cynical and stuff like that
this my point yeah yeah like I said I
agree with you we used we used to have a
unified culture where someone would be
like I wrote here a Christmas tune I
hope you like it number one bang and now
for 70 years it's been a number one or
top 10 song every Christmas we don't
have someone today being like what's up
yo I wrote a Christmas rap and hting a
number one Christmas song Christmas and
hollas by Run DMC is a great song I'm
going to say Run DMC did a Christmas
song Yes Christmas time and holl queen
holl Queens mama's making chicken and
colled greens right right but but my
point Two Towns over from where I GRE my
point is we we we we rarely make new
things culturally their reboots their
remakes is cultural stagnation and we we
you know another example is a better
example we were over at long shots in
pool hall in West Virginia you guys
should check it out if you're in the
area it's a fun place and I go in the
Jukebox I put on Bohemian rap city what
happens everyone starts singing everyone
in the bar there's like 30 some 30 40
people everyone singing Bohemian rap
city yeah I put on modern rock everybody
goes about their business yeah well
there's something about Classics that
makes them classic we we used to be
unified more so and now we are
fragmenting yeah but there's also
something about unique Classics that are
iconic bohemi and RAB city is is is is
Iconic right what song from the past
year could I play that everyone in the
bar would sing I haven't listened to the
radio so long well country station um
yeah I'll I'll um maybe try that in a
small town no maybe Taylor Swift I don't
know I think she the uh horses in the
bag I have no idea uh Oldtown Road
Oldtown road yeah that's probably
something and that's probably because of
kids falling in love with it but that's
probably the the most recent song not a
great song either I I actually don't
think as a song that entire bar would
sing because like the target demo is
like 16-year-old girls no so it's widely
popular and she's massive metall and
fiser that's Metallica but like Enter
Sandman might get a lot of people going
but what we talking about s what year
was that 9933 92 maybe yeah yeah but you
play Billy Joel's Piano Man everyone
will start
singing You've Lost That love and
feeling everyone I mean there are some
songs of yeah I think the the I I get
your point though because there's
there's not a lot of stuff in the past
say 20 years that's really going to get
everybody yeah the '90s was the last
decade yeah so and and you know there
people who are just like I am not making
the argument the 90s was good I'm saying
that the 50s 60s 7s ' 80s and 90s are
discernable time periods with fashion
and music yeah and after the 90s
everything became a blurred splotch that
is why I I was convinced people made
such a huge deal about the death of
Matthew Perry not because they loved the
show Friends not because they
particularly loved or knew him but
because the death of Matthew Perry was
the was the beginning of the death of
the 9s and that was a show that
everybody watched before cell phones
before internet before online
pornography friends was like the last
moment of innocence and so a lot of 39y
olds Matthew Perry died or 25y olds and
they were like that's it childhood is
over it was the last decade all right
red run uh red RX says there's a post on
Reddit from a liberal art student saying
she is broke but wants to manifest
herself a millionaire having lunch with
Bill Gates and Bezos yeah e
manifesting these are people who are
going to be like Society will collapse
and they'll be sitting around being like
I'm going to manifest food and then they
will starve you know what manifesting is
manifesting is praying for people that
are not that don't believe in a god it's
just they say manifest like I'm going to
manifest which means I'm going to send
out positive vibes into the universe
yeah think so when she when she says I
want to manifest Jeff Bezos means like I
want will it into existence yes manifest
means if you focus on it you will make
it happen for you oh that's how it works
and there is a physical reality to this
if every day I wake up and I focus on
playing the guitar I'll get really good
at guitar and guess what you might find
yourself in a successful band but the
idea that you can sit there and not play
your guitar and just like Envision
playing the guitar and that will get you
somewhere ain't going to happen no
that's what these people think holy crap
manifesting yep where's the end got to
manifest the fence line tomorrow to make
sure no trees fell on it yeah flavor
says the US has crossed the Event
Horizon into a debt spiral 40% of our
income tax goes to 1 trillion on
interest owed please get Preston pish or
Jeff Booth on the show hyperinflation
happens gradually then suddenly learn or
be doomed yeah well I don't know about
anybody else and I'm not giving anybody
advice but you know I got Bitcoin so and
gold Fox did you see do you see the the
central banks are buying tons of gold
like crazy gold China Gold's like
$220 China bought a ton of gold I'm
sorry I'm sorry we won't get literal
China bought what like 42 tons of gold
or something like that or 24 Fox did a
thing this morning which I thought was
fascinating they showed Uh Kevin when he
went shopping in home alone right went
to the grocery store what he spent and
what it cost $9 it was 19 like 68 he had
a $20 bill he got some change it was $65
in today's market yeah but in in New
York someone there was an article about
this a couple weeks ago it was like $77
in New York LA and Chicago in have your
has your wages gone up triple right has
I mean insane to think that that's how
much inflation has gone up and and I
would love to look at those prices in
two 2020 because it's gone up 20% since
then but dude man people don't pay
attention I posted this photo we were in
North Carolina and I posted a picture we
bought chips dip like mostly it was like
a couple drinks and like chips and dip
and it was like hundred something
dollars cuz we got salami chips and it
wasn't just chips and dip we got like a
hummus some cheese dip some chips some
crackers and some meat and it was two
bags half full and it was $13 and I was
like what the and then people were like
you faked this it's not true and I was
like what what what am I supposed to do
it's crazy we we buy these salami packs
they're really good we used to buy them
all the time we've been here for three
years and they were like five bucks five
bucks for like three long things and you
peel it open and it's got the resealable
thing and now they're 12 bucks yeah and
they're probably 12% smaller also they
put one less slice in and inflation and
yeah the fact that more people are not a
woke to food prices and food uh is just
is is very
disconcerting all right Frankie low says
education is a bigger racket than you
think college graduates are left without
skills so that way they are forced to
enter grad school and learn the skills
they should have learned in undergrad uh
yes technically they should have learned
most of these skills in grade
school for real you know what you know
what I learned that school you I I I I I
had several moments in my life where I
realized school was a scam and it was um
the one story I like to tell is when I
was a little kid my mom asked me what I
learned when I was in school and I said
uh in 1492 Columbus sailed the ocean
blue he discovered America and she was
like well he didn't discover America
there were people here already and I
went oh well that's what they said at
school and she's like well that's not
true I mean there were already people
here and besides Leaf Ericson got here a
thousand years before Columbus and I was
like huh then why are they lying to me I
was pissed but there was a couple other
moments but then one big one was you
know I didn't go to high school I went
to I went to high school for like two
months and then stopped going uh and did
home correspondence like home school and
it was because uh I started freshman
year and I remember like the first day
they said we were going to have a lesson
on interrogative sentences and I was
like what I was like I I know what
that's an interrogative good I know what
a question is I learned that in
kindergart why am I now in freshman year
of high school and they're teaching us
literally the exact same things we were
learning years and years ago and then I
went I asked people and they were like
oh yeah and then what what really just
ended it for me was I'm sitting in
literature class I'm 14 and the teacher
is like today we're going to read this
story by Mark Twain or whatever and I'm
like okay and then he calls on a student
to read and the kid goes on the first
day
of uh day of an an an encyclopedia ency
encycl uh and I'm like what is happening
right now why am I sitting in this chair
being forced to hear a kid who can't
read at all and that just stopped going
I I lost it I was walking to school I
was 14 one day and fell down started
crying and then I got turned around and
went home and I was like I will never go
back in that building and that was the
end of it that was it I was done I I
tried to do that my parents were like
nope you're com back and I'm like why
this is so pointless this is so
ridiculous this is so stupid I'm not
learning anything um and it was just
brutal I I hated school when we started
we started doing correspondence School
my brother and I were doing two weeks of
public education per
day that I that's it because I think the
average person is like if student if if
human beings are given the opportunity
to learn at the pace they want to learn
you you can go even faster than that it
was just two is like that's what we
wanted to do well that's and that's the
overarching frustration I have with all
these Schoolboard arguments we have in
the teachers union nonsense is that you
know we need to talk about transgender
issues in school and you want to say
your kids are functionally illiterate
right like 50% of them cannot even read
and the other 50% cannot read at grade
level and yet you want to have these
silly conversations about transgenderism
they can't do arithmetic one of the
things that we talked about um about the
crisis of Competency and part of the
reason why part of the reason is because
when it comes to whether it be schools
or whether it be businesses when you
have to focus on things like Dei and
you're you're worried about teaching
people the proper political perspective
and stuff then you have a certain
portion of your productive capacity
that's being eaten up by teaching people
or dealing with things that have nothing
to do with whatever it is that your
Endeavor is supposed to be doing whether
be educating kids building cars whatever
it is if you have Dei in your business
or in your school then you have people
that are occupying their entire day with
things that are totally and completely
unrelated to your your whatever your
your businesses and those type of
Industries or those type of departments
they only tend to expand they hire more
people because they look you you find
the things you're looking for if you got
a girlfriend that's looking for you to
cheat that's accusing you of cheating
and stuff eventually she's going to find
something that confirms what she says
and you're you're going to have a big
old fight she enough for her to vent the
frustrations and the same kind of thing
Serge is nodding his head extremely uh
it's true and that kind of stuff happens
with Dei they're looking for for for
something someone if if your company has
that kind of stuff then someone will go
ahead and say look you know I have this
problem and then Dei they'll go ahead
and like well we need to find some you
know more people to deal with this stuff
it it's it is a self uh what's the word
I'm looking forting yeah self
perpetuating exactly and and it's a
massive problem for all for any industry
or any Endeavor that that brings this on
yeah and and then the company has to
automatically raise prices because you
have to make up for that loss of
productivity ask like a father-son
mechanic shop if every Friday they have
to close for diversity and sexual
harassment training you'll be like well
I then I have to charge more to fix cars
Monday through Thursday because if I
have to spend all day Friday so your
productivity is lost so your prices
increase and now I'm paying more to get
my car serviced because they're spending
all day Friday in in some woke seminar
and you just Echo that across the whole
economy and here we are we're going to
go to the members only show so my
friends smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends head over to
timcast.net it up with an offensive joke
that I that I saw on Instagram and it
was by this female comic we're always
ragging on female Comics but this one's
really good and it's and it and it and
it uses a naughty word that YouTu
doesn't like so I'm going to play it for
you guys but uh smash the like button
like I said you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me personally
at timcast Daniel do you want to shout
anything out uh someone just reached out
to me on Twitter and asked about we're
trying to keep solar Farms out of our
community what's the most important
arguments to do that uh send me a DM and
I'll I'll respond to you this is part of
my my job is to fight big green uh it's
great to be here uh God Bless America
and thanks for having me part of this
conversation Daniel thank you so much
for coming on that was a great
conversation my website is the best
political show.com today we had James
Lindsay tomorrow we are having Dave
Smith on I've been working really hard
members of luk un filter.com get to call
into the members area and into the show
I've done like 10 years worth of content
and videos and do a lot of really extra
things for members all on Luke
unfiltered.com that's the best way to
support me and I can't thank you guys
enough for doing so I forgot to give my
sheep farm a shout out sorry Bristol
Farm Virginia the preeminent sheep farm
in all of Virginia if you like sheep or
want to buy sheep or wool or meat
Bristal Farm Virginia and there's great
pictures of our sheep we have very
beautiful sheep gentlemen I am uh Phil
that remains on Twix I am Phil that
remains official on Instagram the band
is All That Remains you can follow us on
Spotify Apple music uh Pandora
Amazon music YouTube you know the
internet and I am surge.com uh great
show pleasure having you here always
Daniel thank you and yeah the after show
we'll see you all over at timcast.net